[Music]
okay
so this is my spoiler free review
of cobra kai season three now i just
want to say that
i was a huge fan of karate kid as a kid
growing up
and then i hadn't watched the films in
forever they've kind of become a blur to
me
so i decided to rewatch all the films
and then i binged season one and two
recently so where i stand on all this is
that
i think that season one was amazing it
lived up to the hype and i was
really actually disappointed in season
two especially in the second half of
season two
where it became more of a teen drama
and kind of went away from focusing on
the adults of the story
and it also lost a lot of doing comedy
in it which was so well done in season
one now i'm here to tell you
because of this i kept my expectations
right in the middle
loving season one disappointing season
two i'm like okay let's see what season
three is all about
let me just say what is great about
season three
is that it fixes that huge
complaint where it really
really stays away from teen drama and
focuses back on the adults and i mean
if you're gonna look at the screen time
of season three it is mostly on
adult characters we love here and very
little on the students themselves and as
you see
what this show does so well is tying
into the original films
and justifying story lines being brought
in and characters from original films
being brought in to fit
the themes and storyline on the current
show they do it so
well in season three and as you see in
the trailer we're gonna have characters
appear from karate kid 2.
it mostly leans into karate kid 2 season
3
and i was not a fan of croticade to the
film it was my least favorite karate kid
film
yes i like the next karate kid and
karate kid 3 better than karate kid 2.
but i loved what they did with karate
kid 2
here in season 3 it made me appreciate
it more and i think actually
the story lines attached to karate kid 2
and the characters brought back
are the highlights of season 3 for me
what really works now
just with our main character in johnny
lawrence
and his growth as a character is that
as much as i didn't like the finale of
season two and i thought this whole
fight in school was a mess
it was a great catalyst for season three
because as the season starts out you're
gonna see
every character has to react to what
happened to miguel and it shakes
things up which was desperately needed
because the show is starting to feel a
little stagnant
and from that point on the pace is
really good
and they also really develop creases
character really well
and what you're going to see is it's so
well paced between
daniel johnny and chris this season with
a little drop
of the stuff with the students so that
was so effective that they went that way
and they do such a great job of it
and when i come back to how they brought
the comedy back again they lean into
that
johnny being a big kid which is great
some of his lines are just excellent
here again that make you really laugh
the comedy's not as tight as season one
but it's way better than season two's
comedy it made me laugh a lot and it
also
again the show's best when it's feel
good as well and it
does justice to that feel of the
original karate kid movies
it being a little cheesy it having a
heart and
it felt like it hit that magic again in
season three like it did in season one
which i thought was missing in season
two you're gonna see a lot of easter
eggs here
obviously i'm not gonna spoil any of
them but you're gonna be satisfied they
all really do pay off and tie
thematically
really well it's so impressive how much
effort this writing team puts in and
shows how much they really love this
franchise in the films and what's
crazy about season three is it sets up
super hype and excitement for season
four
so i will say that season three is light
years better than season two
not as good as season one but that's a
really hard task season one
is excellent so to live up to that it's
gonna be tough but it's close so
i was really happy with cobra kai season
three i think fans are gonna absolutely
love it
and if you like season two you're
probably not gonna be blown away by
season three because it's ten times
better
so i give season three an eight point
eight now i'm gonna delve into every
single episode of my spoiler review i'm
gonna break down
all my thoughts that will be coming out
when the show comes out so you're not
gonna want to miss that
please let me know down below if you
plan on watching season three what you
thought of the
original movies what you thought of
season one and two any theories you got
for season three i'd love to hear them
and just get the discussion going about
cobra kai as a whole i really want to
hear
everyone's thoughts on it please make
sure to subscribe to my channel it helps
me in so many ways like i said you're
not going to miss that big spoiler
review i'm going to have for the season
and please follow me at steve all the
show on twitter instagram for more of me
and i'll see you next time